I just wanted to point out alexandrov a
crew here who came up with the title how
central is Central Asia which seems to
have been a stroke of genius given how
many references have been made to it so
far so I wanted to be sure that credit
was given where credit is due ah the
third panel for today is on kyrgyzstan a
topic which we probably could have had a
whole day conference as many of the
topics that we have here today and again
a consult your programs for more
detailed information on our speakers but
the panel today will have Scott Horton
who is doing it advisor to the interim
government of Kyrgyzstan and a lecturer
in law at the Columbia Law School Eric
McGlinchey assistant professor of
government and politics at george mason
jar baek ji of dean of academic affairs
at the academic University of Central
Asia bishkek so we do I say American the
American University of Central Asia in
bishkek so we do have a central asian
representative uh here where your enough
and I say Googoosh a keen was assistant
professor of Slavic languages and
literature at Princeton University and
Tom Symonds who is a visiting scholar at
the davis center for russian and
eurasian studies will be the moderator
so I'll turn the floor over to Scott is
going as prism to go first so if you
could join me in welcoming Scott Horton
thank you
thank you i have to start with a
disclaimer so you should pull out your
brochure and where it says I am a
advisor to the interim government of
Cuba Stan just strike through that
that's wrong I don't know where that
came from but it's just not correct i
mean i am a lawyer and I give advice to
clients from time to time and then and
in that capacity you know it it is
undeniable I've given advice to a number
of governments but you know that does
not mean that I in any way have a formal
relationship with them advising them or
that I represent them in any way and I
would hasten to say that the Roosevelt
anvaya if she knew the remarks I was
going to make would would probably very
quickly distance herself from all of
them because i'm going to most of the
most of the comments I've heard so far
most the presentations have been that
this sort of lofty almost stratospheric
niveau so I'm going to reach right into
the ditch and talk about base politics
Alex coolies favorite subject and US
relations I think there's no question
but that the controlling issue in the
u.s. kyrgyz relationship right now is
that its base politics and the critics
of US policies towards kurtistown over
the last five years and that by the way
includes virtually every senior figure
in the current government and virtually
every leadership figure and the parties
are likely to form a new government have
said that have criticized the US
strongly over its posture and have said
that the u.s. cares about nothing but
the base Michael McDowell I think he's
pushed back against that McFall has
pushed back against that bravely but on
balance I'm not sure very convincingly
of course nothing is certainly too
strong and but I think it's also true
that the
bass and the issues relating to it
dwarfed all the other issues and US
diplomats in bishkek have complained
privately sometimes passionately about
the near-monopoly role that the base is
played in their work and of course the
former Kyrgyz ambassador to the United
States bucket up Josiah gave very strong
evidence about this when he wrote
columns in the Wall Street Journal and
The Washington Post in which he
carefully charted the conduct of us
diplomacy towards Kyrgyzstan pre and
post base once the base was open he
wrote the US attitude was governed by
desire to keep it up and running
sometimes to expand it suddenly
elections human rights democracy
education were all issues that just got
dropped by the wayside the State
Department opened its mouth one Kyrgyz
political leader told me and the voice
of the Pentagon pops out and I think the
situation from their perspective reached
its low point with the current
ambassador touching Annika feller she
was she in the accusation that's
levelled against her locally is that she
systematically avoided local opposition
to figures she coddled the dictators
kleptomaniacs son this is a lot from the
rhetoric of the revolution itself in the
days immediately after and after all she
was the wife of the singh kham
commanders senior political adviser now
I I've had dealings with every US
emissary to Kyrgyzstan and i would say
that touch Chanukah feller actually has
been in many ways one of the more
capable American diplomats to serve
their very effective she has a very very
good command of of the local stack of
cards and I think that she was not a
rogue figure there she was implementing
US policy decisions that were taken at
very high levels in Washington a but uh
you know I don't think it's played well
and I'll just give you an example I
think demonstrates encapsulate the
problem from something that happened
just a few weeks ago touchy Anika feller
was invited to give a talk at the
American University and and she did so
it was very well attended it seems that
she gave her talk the the audience
reacted quite positively to it it was
sort of a warm environment and then we
came to the question-and-answer session
as former president akai of knows the
students at the American University in
Central Asia are notorious for asking
very difficult questions potentially
embarrassing questions and touchy Annika
feller had one put to her you know in
light of what's happened over the last
couple of years particularly with the
complaints you've heard from the
government with the avoidance of
opposition political figures with all
the issues of arisen surrounding the
base don't you think there's some
mistakes that were made would you do
wouldn't you do things differently and
and the ambassador's response was
basically complete denial refusal to
accept that there were such mistakes in
the whole atmosphere and the room
changed from being warm to being icy
cold turned on a dime right there and I
think that really encapsulate the
problem with the u.s. kyrgyz
relationship right now because I think
the Kyrgyz expected post-revolution to
see some changes and the way the United
States did business in their country
they expected to see more transparency
and the shift in priorities they
expected to see a justification for the
base in terms of shared conceives and
support for for other areas things like
education for instance in terms of
rhetoric there has been a shift and
Michael McFaul in particular I think has
been a master at this he gets good marks
from people i've talked to there for
some of the radio interviews and
speeches he's given but people are
really looking to see how that works
itself out in the way the US government
behaves particularly
the dealings that get a lot of attention
surrounding the base and what I think
most people see so far and this is I've
just returned from bishkek am I talked
with pretty much all the party leaders
and ask some questions about this new
attitude towards the base what they see
is no change they see straight line
continuity with the past they see a sort
of contemptuous insistence that the
United States did nothing wrong and
insistence that that the criticisms that
were leveled at the US were incorrect
but in fact I don't think there is any
more transparency concerning us
operations especially relating to the
base now than there was before at one
thing specifically I mean the kirghiz
government was told that there will be
postings to the embassy website about
payments on the base and about all the
details of the contract tender there
have been some postings but by and large
information about the payments for
instance has not been posted not this
very very simple thing but I think it's
it's it really makes the point very
clearly and I think the aviation fuels
tender is something that gets an awful
lot of attention and and I think in some
sense is defining of this relationship
in the sense it seems sort of odd why
would one particular contract to sell
aviation fuel at an air base be such a
high-profile matter it may be that it is
for irrational reasons I'm not sure on
the other hand inside of Kyrgyzstan its
scene is like El Dorado the lost city of
gold immense riches I mean this in
throughout Kyrgyzstan days there's a
mess understanding that people have made
massive fortunes off of this aviation
fuel supply business I certainly have no
idea if that's true but I know that it's
the perception than the perception is
having a very very strong
impact that I know of course that the
total volume of these fuel contracts as
the house could which by the way the
Defense Department was at ends never to
add up fully you know has been tallied
by the House Oversight Committee and
they're coming up with about 3.6 billion
dollars which is an awful lot of money
so of course if one assumes that there's
a fifteen percent profit margin on 3.6
billion dollars yes that that is the
Kirghiz equivalent of the lost city of
El Dorado so we have a hearing before
the House Committee on Oversight in
April 22nd Alex Cooley was was there
testifying to I did as well and at the
end chairman journey asked what should
happen with these contracts i think our
panel of witnesses were unanimous in
saying it really should be put up for
rebid and it should be completely
transparent there should be a fair
opportunity for every call concerned to
to participate so that the holder of
this contract will have some legitimacy
and the in fact the contract was
withdrawn a new tender process was set
out so has that restored by the way the
winner of that process is set to be
announced very very very soon i think
before the close of business on monday
i'm being told over and over again but
you know has that restored confidence in
the u.s. process no is the senior Kyrgyz
political official told me the American
process is about as fair and transparent
as a government contract award in
Uzbekistan the the Department of Defense
was from the outset focused on a
defensive posture about this mustering
vehemence and explaining that the
contract that had was the best of all
possible worlds was being brilliantly
performed that there was no reason and
no reason to expect it could ever be
improved upon basically making a
continuous very strong argument for
continuity which is by the way why no
one has any doubt what they're going to
announce some monday i mean it's
certainly going to be straight
continuity with what was done in the
past and I think very very few people
have any confidence that it was in fact
a fairly administered a bid competition
in fact people in Kyrgyzstan have no
confidence in that based on a lot of
stories that are being spread around
there about things that happened in the
course of the contract administration I
expect we'll probably see some Press
reports about that shortly but in the
course of I mean think from the
perspective of the kyrgyz government the
contract award really was important so
what one thing was was the winner of
this contract going to be a good
corporate citizen in Kyrgyzstan were
they going to register have employees
there have a legal form pay taxes do
they're withholding etc because the
current ssds contracts have been
administer up to this point there is no
legal compliance nor is that required by
the Department of Defense and on this
department of defense again took an
unequivocal position there was no need
for the contract recipient to be
concerned about legal compliance in
Kyrgyzstan not with having a legal
vehicle they're not with paying taxes
and and indeed indeed I interviewed
several of the participants who
disclosed to me how they were informed
that this is one of the big advantages
of the contract is that you don't have
to worry about all of that now that is
per se corrupt and it's a violation of
the internationally accepted norms for
government procurement contracts which
were articulated and hammered out with
considerable impact and influence from
the United States by the way by the
World Bank so why does the Department of
Defense completely depart from these
rules why does it take the position that
the Kyrgyz state is implicitly some sort
of failed polity you just don't have to
worry about maybe to be pushed around
and maybe to be dealt with by handing
paper bags to government figures filled
with who knows what
now it's true that the United States
negotiated a special tax regime
concerning the sales of fueled among us
but that doesn't free the company from
operating on care Gasol and compliance
with Kyrgyz law including the obligation
to register and to pay taxes lawfully
accruing on its operations that includes
income taxes social security
contributions withholding on employees
and you wouldn't be able to run this
operation without 20 to 30 of them at a
minimum the current operations as I
noted show no compliance and no concern
and that this is not a matter of concern
to the Pentagon but it does undermine
the integrity of the Kyrgyz state and it
contributes to the broad perception of
corruption in the marketplace especially
surrounding the United States just two
days ago transparency international
issued its new index on corruption
around the world and I think frankly
it's no surprise that when we look at
the bottom at the seller of the most
corrupt nations in the world we find it
okya we find that is filled with
countries that are occupied by the
United States where a large part of
their economy comes from US government
administered contracts so this is the
epicenter of global corruption and I
think there's a lot of concern that in
Kyrgyzstan we're going to see a further
slide they have serious corruption
problems a lot of concern that the
United States instead of helping the
move away from corruption is actually
fomenting an atmosphere of corruption
kyrgyzstan's proposed response has been
to have a Kyrgyz state company
resurrected to receive the contracts I
don't think that's necessarily any less
corrupt than having private companies it
just produces a new a new type of
problem but i think president otunba
Yahveh to her the torah credit has
proposed a whole series of measures with
independent outside oversight bodies and
all sorts of government checks to to
check or limit the potential for
corruption now the Kyrgyz are
focus on the fact that in other
countries around the world when the
government says we have a state fuel
supply company and we want you to do
business with them the Pentagon has no
problem saying yes will do that in fact
you can look at the recent no bid deal
they've just done with with the
government of Abu Dhabi but when it's
Kyrgyzstan that's involved suddenly the
Pentagon has a very different attitude
and they want to push back in favor of
their favorite and that's I think
interesting and disturbing to the key
issue here was and remains transparency
and I think the u.s. is very it's
incumbent on the u.s. to show some
leadership in this process to push the
transparency issue to push legal
compliance to insist that its
contractors not accept or receive bribes
that they give undertakings to behave
consistently with the legal regime none
of that's been done and I think that's a
that's a great disappointment here and
the end the question really is whether
the US is going to approach and work
with Kyrgyzstan as a sister democracy
with its own peculiar problems or
whether it's going to view Kyrgyzstan as
a failed state in which the u.s. acts to
protect its national security needs and
the way that disrespects the host
state's political institutions and legal
culture and so far what we've seen from
the United States has been some positive
rhetoric and absolutely no meaningful
carry through by the Department of
Defense thank
Eric McGlinchey thank you for inviting
me to talk today I'd like to extent that
I can present three puzzles that I think
a lot of us have been pondering for the
past well in one case the past couple
months but in many cases the past two
decades and this is a modular
presentation I know I've got 15 minutes
i'm already pushing it there a little
bit but I if I don't get to the last one
perhaps we can get to that later but the
first one I want to look at is why
Kyrgyzstan is so chaotic why it's okay
otic and I have two other points up
there next to chaos that is violence in
dynasty and the way to understand i
would argue i cure gustan is so chaotic
is to compare it to its neighbors that
have very different kind of post-soviet
outcomes that is violence in uzbekistan
and mainly a predominate a primary focus
on creating a dynasty in kazakhstan so
i'll try to understand Kyrgyzstan by
comparing it to what it's not that is
violent in Uzbekistan and dynasty in
Kazakhstan so this is kind of a cross
case way to get at instability in
Kyrgyzstan but there's also another
puzzle that I want to dress and that is
curious town has become increasingly
chaotic over the past two decades if you
look at akai of stay in power 1992 2005
as far as an autocrats concerned that's
a pretty good run 15 years in power is
not bad but Kiev he was only in power
for five years so we have been
interesting with in case puzzle as well
and that is why is cure gustan become
increasingly chaotic over time I'll try
to address that and then lastly if
there's any time remaining I'd like to
address the unfortunate event of these
cure geez f Kyrgyz Uzbek ethnic riots
over the summer and present some
preliminary conclusions based on some
field research in basrah Corgan and
Jalalabad in july so that that's what I
hope to do let me just frame what the
arguments going to be in
what the ideas that I'm drawing on I'll
be looking at a number of different
causal arguments here one is a path
dependency argument and something that
is somewhat unusual for political
science I'll talk a little bit about
history and to understand that first
puzzle that I have up there I think you
really have to look at Soviet history in
particular late perestroika history the
second thing i'll be looking at is what
we would call rational choice but
basically the idea that greed matters
and that people are motivated by returns
and in some cases as with the turkeys
executive very high economic returns and
then the last thing i'll be looking at
if i get to the third puzzle is this
question of elite agency and the
argument that will be making here is a
tomb bava as much as we may value her
Democratic desires nevertheless as an
autocrat she failed authoritarianism 101
and I think we could say a lot of what
happened in June is a result of a tomb
by Ava's misunderstanding of how
autocracy runs in Kyrgyzstan and for
those of you who are trying to kind of
scituate where these causalities are I
mean some of this you can understand at
a very broad level and in the argument
i'll be making with the first puzzle is
an argument that i think you can draw in
and extend to multiple cases not just
the cure gives an uzbek in Kazakh cases
so this argument can travel to other
places the argument that i'll be making
about growing instability in Kyrgyzstan
1992 2005 vs2005 to 2010 is an economic
resources argument and that might be
more of a mid-range finding perhaps one
that doesn't travel that far outside of
developing countries that receive a lot
of economic aid but i'll also be telling
a story about elites and the decisions
they make and this will be a very
central asia elite focused argument if
you want to walk away with just a story
about central asia you can do that as
well okay let me get to the first puzzle
this idea of chaos in Kyrgyzstan
violence in Uzbekistan and dynasty and
Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan I've already
mentioned has to has had two changes of
government I call them kuz or pushes
other people call them revolution and
people fight about this I discovered in
July when people started yelling at me
but I yeah I maintain that these are
cruise if you look at who's becca ston
you've had one guy in power for a long
time but he's held on to power by
killing lots of people so there's a lot
of violence there one only needs to look
at on Dijon in 2005 to understand how
this works but at a more immediate level
colleagues that I've been working with
like me Tania's ova raja muhammad oov
and unfortunately the worst outcome here
Ali share Sahib of these are all people
who have been repressed or killed
journalists who've been repressed or
killed or look at the political
opposition recently there's a piece in
The Times about Sanjay Kumar of and the
horrible ordeal that he went through
this is an incredibly violent government
so the question is why is this place so
violent kazakhstan in many cases is is
the best outcome that you have now
there's some there's some repression
here people like Joe fgs and jockey on
of implosive have all run into some
difficulties with the current government
but they're not tortured they're not
they're not usually they're not killed
it's not that bad place to be in
opposition comparatively speaking the
biggest worried that the Kazakh
government has is one of dynasty and we
already saw what happened with raha
Holly if he published a book in 2009
called god father in law and that didn't
sit too well with his godfather I mean
the President and he is no longer the
heir apparent the new person is teamwork
cool ebuyer the other son-in-law coolie
by viz hedging his bets apparently he
has a mansion in in the UK and a
girlfriend in the UK just ready to go
just in case he falls out of power or
out of choice but this is you get the
idea this is the point in Kazakhstan the
main issue is you know who's going to
follow Nasser by of when na Surabaya
decides that he's bored with being
president for life and so that the the
question is well why do we get these
variations and I I'd like to suggest
that we get these variations for a
pretty straightforward reason and that
is these are very different countries
and their fault they're flying very
different planes what do I mean by that
karastan you can imagine as a little
plane a Cessna with not that many people
in fact we could imagine that this is
this is kyrgyzstan here and scott and
shire becca are my copilot and navigator
and if scott and shire beck get upset
with me
they can say we don't like McGlinchey
anymore and let's toss them out of the
out of the plane but to do that they're
gonna have to enlist the support of the
other people on the plane we've got two
more people on the plane and it would
probably pretty easy to convince the
rest of the people on the plane to throw
me out because if I'm out of power then
everybody else is going to get most
likely will get a cut of the pie it's a
very small political elite there is an
interest to overthrow the executive and
it's not that hard to coordinate action
to overthrow the executive now if this
were the political elite this entire
room Scott and Chie Beck would probably
think twice before doing this right now
I'm paying Scott a little bit i'm
playing ping Shire back a little bit and
that you know they're getting a cut of
the pie now this is the entire political
elite here it's a very large plane it's
a Boeing 747 Scott might think well you
know we overthrow McGlinchey and some
other guy comes into power what's the
likelihood that this other guy is
actually going to include me in the new
winning coalition I might be out there
sitting in the audience rather than up
front here flying the plane so people
think twice in the case of Uzbekistan
and Kazakhstan before chain before
challenging the rule of the executive
classic classic coordinated action
dilemma here the question though is
where do these different planes come
from what's we know why did why is
kyrgyzstan cessna wise kazakhstan
uzbekistan a 747 the answer here is path
dependency in the history i would say
all of these countries during the
perestroika period experienced ethnic
riots in 1986 Kazakhstan had ethnic
riots in 1989 who's becca john-- hideki
the ethnic rights and in 1990 kyrgyzstan
had ethnic riots the timing of these
riots are critically important in 1990
in February 1990 Gorbachev for reasons
that are more related to Moscow politics
and the Central Asian politics said you
know it's time to get rid of the
Communist Party you wanted to get rid of
the dead wood in the Communist Party by
exposing at the competition now this is
all fine and well for trying to get rid
of dead wood but if you have a reveler
own uprising in your country after this
decision Roberta more or less says
you're going to go your own way we're
not going to intervene anymore then
there's no one to come in to restore
order
after your incredibly unstable izing
destabilizing event so whereas Gorbachev
in the party intervened in 1986 in
Kazakhstan intervened in 1989 in
Uzbekistan to in essence restore the
Uzbek and kasich communist party to a
hole in Kyrgyzstan when they had their
riots in june nineteen ninety there was
no mosque out to intervene the Kyrgyz
political elite crumbled fractured and
more or less became the Curie's
political elite that you see today the
same people who are rotating in and out
of power today many of them were the
same people who stuck around stuck
around in this increasingly small plane
in 1990 whereas a lot of other people
just simply left the politically it's a
much smaller politically so that's the
answer I would argue for the first
puzzle a couple things that I want to
draw your attention to just to briefly
talk about the violence in Uzbekistan
and the dynasty in Kazakhstan this slide
here represents Uzbek and cure geez
public goods provision as a percentage
of Kazakh public goods provision now
Pauline was hitting on this a little bit
in her presentation there are a lot of
resources in Kazakhstan for reasons that
the previous plan panel pointed to and
the the wonderful thing for na survive
is he can afford to give out a lot of
public goods there's considerably less
public goods in Uzbekistan it's this
much smaller economy in fact is Pakistan
on many scores performs less well than
Kyrgyzstan there's less less to go
around to poor economy in Kyrgyzstan is
a much smaller economy public is
provision is very low what implication
does this have well you know one of the
other interesting things that's happened
in Central Asia since 1990 has been a
growth in interest in Islam and this has
been most market in Kyrgyzstan and
Uzbekistan of excellent actually started
off at a relatively high place to begin
with but the the story here is that when
you have a state that can't provide
public goods that can't take care of its
population often times you get other
alternative societies that provide this
in Kyrgyzstan which yet you have a weak
state to begin with this isn't so much
of a problem because the curious they
can't do anything about this
Uzbekistan karima finds us to be a very
big threat you go to the Fergana Valley
you look around and you see who's doing
stuff it's not the state it's a lot of
these local Muslim charities and as we
already know from onda John in 2005
karima finds this to be challenged 12
was a legitimacy into to his authority
so every now and then when these Muslim
elites get a little bit too powerful he
cracks down on them again on Dijon is
the most blatant example this but
there's been steady repression of Muslim
elites throughout the past two decades
this is why I argue you get the violence
in Uzbekistan and and and you don't get
that much violence in Kazakhstan again
because you have much more resources
incidentally you also don't have the
same degree of islamic revivalism I'll
skip this I think I've got three minutes
so let me try to get to let me try to
get to the second puzzle about growing
growing Kyrgyz instability the the cut
that i gave you initially was 1992 2005
that was a Kai's stay in power 1992 2001
these were the salad days for a quyth
although acai didn't really recognize
this at the time things were relatively
stable from 1990 till 2001 and the
argument that I'll paint in short form
here is that the reason why things were
relatively stable in 1992 2001 isekai of
the resources that he was receiving was
predominantly predominantly foreign
economic aid foreign aid and he couldn't
easily capture this the thing about
economic aid from us a tour from other
multilateral organizations are these are
things that are directed towards say
education reform towards economic reform
towards towards the health ministry and
when the kaiark this aid in he had to
distribute this to other political
elites in the country he couldn't
directly capture this aid something very
interesting happened in 2001 and Scott
has already talked about this we began
to see the opening of the base and the
base payments that were in contrast to
foreign economic aid and conscious to
foreign economic aid the base payments
were very easily captured by the Kyrgyz
executive so again you can imagine Shire
Beck and Scott looking at me
the executive suddenly taking all the
money rather than sharing it and this
idea that's very easy to throw overthrow
the executive this is what happened with
the cure keys politically beginning in
2001 and until we saw the overthrow in
2005 people were very upset with the
executive taking all the money and they
did what they did they threw the
executive out of the Cessna 2005 to 2010
but Kiev did more or less the same thing
that acai was doing that was taking the
base payments and using it to enrich
himself I've received questions about
this causality well how come but Kiev
didn't recognize the kies mistake and
share the wealth I think the Kiev had a
very short time horizon and really
wanted to take as much money as he
possibly could full well knowing that he
wasn't going to be in office all that
long the other thing is is how can you
how can you turn down this money that I
think Scott described very well billions
of dollars how can you can just walk
away from it it's a very difficult thing
to do lastly the deadly ethnic riots one
minute and let me just give you one idea
about these deadly ethnic rides and that
is on April 7 2010 right after the
interim government came to power Rosa
pumba in my friend a deal by solve and
others made the decision that we do not
want to be associated with this corrupt
autocratic Parliament these people are
distasteful we want to demonstrate that
we're Democrats they got rid of the
Parliament my central idea here is that
the rush to create the formal
institutions of democracy replaces
corrupt Parliament undermined the
informal illiberal yet nevertheless
stabilized stability enhancing
institutions of autocracy the parliament
traditionally in Kyrgyzstan has been a
way that the executive has been able to
reach out to the regional leads any I
take a look at pauline's work on
regionalism in Kyrgyzstan it's been a
way to reach out to the regional ease to
bring them into the ruling coalition to
try to exert Authority unfortunately
ought to imbibe it didn't recognize this
alienated the southern Kyrgyz politic
elite one fellow music math of in
particular and lost control of the south
there's more to it than that but I would
say that's the central mistake that she
made when she came to power thank you
sure back good afternoon everyone I'm
pleased to be the only Central Asian
someone was looking for central where
Central Asians are so here I am and
probably it's both encouraging and sad
that Kristen is again highlighted as the
only Central Asian country to be
discussed in such a conference which is
about Central Asia in general and this
sadness and positiveness overlaps with
the dichotomy of the question what cake
is done has to export to Central Asian
countries and in the Sun policy and
academic circles in Central Asia can
hear that kickstand may be able to
export democracy meaning not democracy
but the openness of thinking and action
and instability it depends on who
defines this for kazakh president and
Uzbek present that might be doing
something and for cake is liberals
another thing but one overall the
question is clear that once again for
the third time cake is done has a new
leadership coming with the promise of
liberalizing the popo system first was a
chi often but keith came and now one by
one but once again the question is what
how this time will sing go after 2005
there was a huge optimism because it was
the first time when such a thing
happened in central asia but in late
years of bucky if it was clear that
things should have gone differently so
but still right after april there was a
quite good deal of optimism you would
read drastically compare Orton x over to
Bucky and see that this is much
completely different personality
probably autumn by Iowa is the only one
in current carries bulk elite who you
can call probably non crop
not linked the dirty deals and probably
a person who more or less understands
liberal democracy the first person was a
kite and second probably certain buyer
and there unlike in 2005 the new interim
government made it clear that they will
not form the government unless or before
they change the constitution and the
constitution measures included the
clauses which would prevent any
political leader or party from emerging
as the only owner of the power and the
somehow they got this constitution past
one another way and then now have
elections who had elections very
recently but as you see observers are
not optimistic despite all these
preconditions that you would expect
Kingston to be returning to the path of
junior democratization press the number
of pessimists are growing even probably
compared to 2005 and there the question
is so why why is this alex plain analogy
probably is quite helpful but probably
it could be somehow enriched probably
this is not about the size of the plane
but the quality of fuel that the plane
had from the very beginning and the some
planes go stable and some up and down up
and up and down depending on the quality
of em joint and quota food probably
available and they the way that food is
disabled among the those who sit in the
plane and there I would like to
highlight three characteristics of
cookies politics or society that for me
can't seem to be the key factors that
explain the dynamics in cake is politics
one is of course it's quite clearly the
weakness of the state it's been from the
very beginning yoga state failed to
create create the system
the economic system which would sustain
itself people were left either to get
depend on the foreign aid or go to
Russia Kazakhstan to feed their families
the state failed to establish rule of
law absolutely it failed to create a
functioning bureaucrat bureaucracy or
bureaucratic system and the two
oversoul's within five years as well as
the events in June just quiet they must
demonstrate the way how state has been
failing the function of course this is
not to say that the government
completely failed but the state as such
has not been performing the way to
ensure that people would obey whatever
comes from the state second thing is the
social fragmentation or social political
fragmentation I could say politics in
Kyrgyzstan remain extremely local or
local istic and all the elections and
revolutions or cools however you call it
tend to have very local roots in 2005 in
parts of Kyrgyzstan the whole thing was
seen as the one clan replacing the
another one in 2010 you have the same
thing several people from several
villages get together overthrow and
claim that now we have the revolution
political ideologies remain absolutely
alien as in 1990s today we have Social
Democrats communists Liberal Democrats
but when it comes down to actual voting
behavior or the way how politicians act
you see that these are just empty words
is I can respect to the conventional
political system that exists in the
world that you have to be a party member
a party leader and so on parties are
better labeled as northern based or
thousand based as of now lots of people
talk that probably will end up with
thousand opposition in the parliament
and so on because it's not entirely
correct however this
points to the fact that politics is main
really localized and very much driven by
the kind of basically local dynamics
even when we have proportional
representation now and the competition
of parties if you look at the way how
campaigning was at done you see that
each party leader on the list was from
certain area and he was all she was
responsible to get X number of votes
from that district if that Lisa didn't
give enough votes that person will not
become a polymer even if he or she is
number five in the list and that was
openly acknowledged by party leaders
that so this is the same single-minded
district elections under the guise of
party-list elections and these things
tend to demonstrate the way how a
citizenship is a concept is still a lien
for the Inca Gaston there's a weak sense
of citizenship and belongingness to the
nation-state and this combined is
combined with another factor which is
unfortunate for kyrgyzstan which is
extremely high level of external
dependence or dependence on external
factors and actors ack i've started with
selling the idea of democracy in
exchange for the favor from the this
part of the world now things hasn't
changed much our political leaders are
selling the form of government now as
you know one of the parties or numbers
for example constructed the whole
election campaign on his meeting with
President Medvedev and using that I
agree midweight with Medvedev on on the
on the idea that presidential rule is
the one for Kristen of course that can
be implies that the others like Social
Democrats autumn akin bring another idea
parliamentary form which is not rushing
back but like us back they don't tell
that but they it's not really about
whether us is really supporting some
parties or Russia is supporting it
about construction the party leaders
themselves created this picture that I
am russia-backed and he is us-backed of
course I believe that we don't really
have genuinely Pro Russian or American
or even anti rational anti-american
forces in Kyrgyzstan they are very much
more primitive but this being used to
come in campaigning and the hope all
these projects beat a parliamentary form
of government of presidential remain not
indigenously developed inside the
Kurdistan within the political elite of
Kyrgyzstan but rather used for certain
particular purposes in the poltical
struggle these things have certain
implications this is not aimed to be
kind of pessimistic view of Kyrgyzstan
this is the way how it is and i think it
was useful that Eric went down to Soviet
history in Kyrgyzstan you have some
people who suggest that we should go
actual to pre Soviet history to
understand the current kill bees
dynamics we do have the competition
strong competition but without any
respect to rule of law to the
Constitution to the political ideologies
but based on loyalty to your brother to
your family member to extended families
and so on and in this sense it seems
that there is no there are little chance
for the strong authoritarian leader to
emerge as well as for a strong
democratic government and there are in
this sense I think it's quite big
question for the US democracy promotion
efforts is how then we can help
Kyrgyzstan to develop a functioning
government the functioning state it's
tough question because it's easy to help
parties NGOs but probably it's hard to
change the society so that the rule of
law the written written law formal law
becomes the primary thing primary norm
as opposed to informal local istic
the best norms which still exist and
which seem to prevail over everything
else well I'll stop here and there we
can discuss the rest in the
question-and-answer session okay thanks
Sergey hi I'm sorry um I I want to
confess to begin with I'm in minority
here I'm anthropologist and it's sort of
a dying out species of social scientists
so I thought I would start my talk by
explaining what is it that actually has
entrepot lidge's do so usually it means
that we tend to pay more attention to
the ways that people on the ground not
look in the sky when the clouds are so
what people on the ground use in order
to frame structure and explain their own
behavior sometimes such explanations are
called local knowledge sometimes they
seen as alternative forms of rationality
which regardless of the actual label the
main professional message behind this
approach and dissertation attention is
the same people behave in a particular
way because they have cultural reasons
to do so to put it simply social
behavior is rarely seen by
anthropologist as reactive and
decontextualized rather social actions
are perceived as many fish
manifestations of particularly embedded
and embodied knowledge I think it is
precisely this embodiment disembodied
and practice knowledge that makes
Central Asia in general in Kyrgyzstan
the particular extremely interesting for
scholars of social transformations in
the sense the post-soviet space could be
seen when we say again as an
anthropological laboratory of sorts
during the last 20 years we have been
witnessing how former Soviet republics
activated very very different
interpretive tools in order to grasp and
to map out the
is off and making Soviet life it's
Caroline come free I'm an anthropologist
at mongolian we're at him aptly called
it so this year spent about five months
in bishkek am i arrived in February
before the Revolution or the pooch and I
left in in in mid-june after the
programs in the south and during this
month and I interviewed the broad
spectrum of people from experts
consulting the government to local
artisans filmmakers and NGO activists
and I want to understand how local
people made sense out of what was
happening in the country during the last
two decades so in today I want to touch
upon two main points each of which has
to do with some aspects of this post's
of it um transformation the points are
the theme of so-called identification
failure of the independent Kurdistan and
the emphasis on particularity and
anthropological difference typical for
many post utopian societies so all of
them are linked with local
interpretations of democracy and
democratic practices in post
totalitarian social societies and I will
use only a few examples to decatur in
trends but this example could be easily
am expanded so let me start with an
identification failure or identification
line notation so in 2007 I am a group of
scholars from bishkek associated with
american university published results of
the assessee illogical study of the
national identity in Kyrgyzstan
supported by the friedrich ebert
foundation the group constructed a
series of poles can conduct the series
of posts I'm among the residents of
Kyrgyzstan asking people to identify
communities that they would like to be
part of what you remain apart so the
results fifty-five percent picked the
category citizens of Kyrgyzstan as their
primary community 55 native 9039 family
31 ethnic group 16 generation 9.4
religion six central asia is a region
five profession and 2.6 picked the
kinship group as their primary community
so the numbers are interesting by
themselves and the question do they
really look like reality but is it
really important time in as many
sociological opposed it's not the
numbers that are important it's like
people make out of them right so what I
find most interesting is the way this
local scholars decided to interpret this
statistics so funny I'm the fact that
only 55 respondents fifty-five percent
of respondents decided to identify
themselves with the state for their
residency was the ultimate example of
what they called a complete
identification failure Paul nadie
difficult only election the kogi state
the scholars insisted and i quote is not
commonly recognized as a viable
institution and it is not commonly
perceived as a viable factor in people's
life and robert just mentioned i'm a
very similar on point right and this
rather common point of view on but what
could we make out of this interpretation
for me it demonstrates a widely shared
assumption that we could find across the
post-soviet board from Latvia and
Belarus Turkmenistan and Kyrgyzstan
namely the routine privilege in the role
of the state in defining people's
priorities in people's identities
despite 20 years of post-soviet
experience we are still dealing with the
fundamentalist Soviet perception
adderall and function on the state
personal identity certainly is not the
only context in which the prominence of
the state is discussed the right to a
other major discourse that are currently
very popular in bishkek and also did my
fieldwork in the fall in Minsk and you
get exactly the same pic picture the
first major topic is the narrative of
sovereignty again like with its striking
emphasis on the ultimate value of this
state and the second one is the
narrative of geopolitical challenges and
again it places the state in the center
of the struggle with all this serve as
often hostile world players and who
allocated a nearby so sometimes though
identification failure is expressed in
positive terms to not so much as a
failure which rather as a manifestation
of multiple identities and just to give
you a to give you a flavor but i want to
quote from a book about the tulip
revolution it's the previous one written
by a controversial businessman and
politician and change back am i relieved
there are live right thing translate how
do our ideology is democracy this means
west our spirituality is a slum this
means east our finish impressed for is
with Russia this means north our
neighbor is China this means south yet
the only geopolitical priority that we
have and all will always will have is
our country girgis tan so why such an
emphasis on the state what kind of
cultural framework make this
geopolitical priority a reasonable
partly as I mentioned we are dealing
with the consequences of the Soviet
period when the party state effectively
monopolized public and private space
there's something else going on them
like many other / social states
kyrgyzstan is negotiating its postulate
status by trying to implement the
traditional model of the nation-state
and here is the twist like some other
examples of it states most notable
indian belarus Kyrgyzstan is trying to
build a nation state without having
finish any shared and distinct of what
the nation park in the couple nation
state is going to be and the posted i
quoted earlier are very symptomatic in
this sense the category of nation was
not on the list of the available
communities in this of course is not
accidental until very recently I think
it's 2009 determination was not departed
the public discourse in Kyrgyzstan media
and politicians and I'm talking only
about a russian-speaking media and
continue to use the notion people the
road if all the primordial connotations
that this term brings then this thing of
the nation as a socio-political
institution and as a possible
counterbalance to the state by and large
is still missing so to go back to the
idea about identification failure what
we have them here is not so much a
failure to identify with a particular
model of the nation which rather a
failure to articulate to formulate to
shape in the graspable manner a vision
of the nation that could be shared by
the residents of the country and this
brings me to my second point about
democracy as particularity a lack of a
clear vision on the Kyrgyz nation after
socialism of course has some structural
reasons partly this cultural resistance
to generalize is a reaction to the
Soviet history with its blanket notions
of the Soviet collectivity and the city
personality the tentative not to raised
at least to ignore local variations and
specificities from that point of view
the possibility kids I have been a
period of celebration of cultural
difference faceless senior geologist of
the previous period were replaced by
highly distinctive forms of economic
cultural political religious and ethnic
diversity the celebration of course
comes with the price without the overall
framework the fragmentation of Soviet
totality the increasing differentiation
of social fabric could result in a
peaceful or not so peaceful and version
of balkanization in the process that
Katherine Bajoran another anthropologist
call some time ago the feudal ization of
post-socialist society's totality in
other words decomposes into a loose
conglomerate of barely connected social
unit in Kyrgyzstan and unlike many other
places providers get an interest in
worldly demonstrates how the extreme
fragmentation on the social fabric is
negotiated against the backdrop of a
very weak state and the nation that has
used to be Hesiod has yet to be and
consolidated first all the social
fragmentation is perceived as the
disappearance of the center in some
cases experts are talking about the
principle of locally so anja rubik was
talking about that let's started
dominating political and cultural
exchanges from the version of radical
originalism in other words as the local
expression goes new version I biografia
a Virgina geografia it is not the it is
not the biography that pairs it is the
geography of your origin that counts yet
my favorite conceptualization of the
situation comes from report that a group
of experts Kyrgyz expert prepared last
August for the government in a report
experts are talking about mass
marginalization muscle a marginal
results at the Kyrgyz society of course
the term it's by itself makes no sense
logically speaking mass marginalization
is not marginalization but it makes a
lot of sense economically and culturally
waiting to the perceived disappearance
of political and cultural work so unlike
many other pursued States Kyrgyzstan has
been dealing with this much
marginalization through a unique
combination of traditional and
contemporary strategies traditional one
is perhaps the most striking and has to
do with the cultural and political
reanimation of the rhetoric on kingship
and tribalism there is a cottage
industry
of academic publications that
demonstrates how the recent political
history of the country was already
determined by the kinship connections
and local links of curious politicians
America is striking list in striking the
structural structuralist fashion
politics and central asia in central
agency in the Central Asian state
emerges in an example from the book by
claude lvi-strauss the elementary
structure structures of kingship but not
one crucial exam exception instead of
women circulating between different
tribes we have political offices and
political positions that cement the
clans and play the role of vital
currency the fact that the reanimated to
a dragon keep on kingship is used as an
alternative form of political and social
stratification is obvious and by saying
this I do not mean to apply that these
clans and tribes I part of local
mentalities some scholars office suggest
rather I want to emphasize that this
rhetoric is an effective tool that helps
to explain structure and justify social
fragmentation in the last 20 years in
other words I want to reverse the in the
model that Arabic offered it's not the
fragmentation it sort of creates
instability it's an inability to come up
with the general framework that produces
in constant reserve precipitates our own
fragmentation Sookie ship narratives are
narratives to the capable of balance in
a desire to articulate difference in
particularity on the one hand and I need
to maintain some degree of universality
on the on the other there's one more
important aspect to this symbolic
framework term when occurred is the
activation of the genealogical rhetoric
is a way to narrate one's own biography
outside the Soviet or socialist context
genealogy then becomes a new way of
inscribing oneself in the newly
constructed history of the country in a
way it is a localized attempt to regain
personal sovereignty if only
symbolically and you know be an
anthropologist we have very attached to
material objects so I feel like I would
bring a look I'm an example so this
sickness this is a book by a local
scholar called Kyrgyzstan on the way of
trade sovereignty on on the way off its
sovereignty and look it's the basic
political science book that provides a
general overview of
political history of Kyrgyzstan yet what
we have in the very end this book is
sort of a biography of the scholar
written by somebody else and this
biography is supplemented by sort of get
another form of biography it's precisely
this genealogy that I am talking about
right so you could trace yeah in
finishing soon even you could tracer of
the alternative canal I genealogy of
disorder and that becomes pretty common
right so that becomes were part of the
academic canon and serve it circulated
throughout right so the kingship
discourse simultaneously celebrates and
contains social and cultural difference
appealing to tradition the other perhaps
equally powerful discourse indifference
and practice of particular on
description difference in practice of
particularity is entirely possible and
it has to do with the incredible
proliferation at the non-governmental
movement in independent Kyrgyzstan again
to give you some numbers in 1991 the
country had 340 NGOs in 1999 more than
3,000 in 2004 more than nine thousand
and two thousand seven more than 13,000
rented many of these organizations exist
were existed only on paper and it's also
true as i was told that it's much easier
to open to register a new organization
that to shut down the one that ceased to
function still despite all the inflation
the numbers staggering and they did you
reflect a trend that has no parallel in
the former Soviet Union obviously there
is a lot of commonality between the
rhetoric and kinship and the NGO
movement both organizing structure
social interactions both provide
participants with recognizable social
positions there is a major difference
though unlike the kinship structure the
NGO movement produces a new type of the
democratic citizen who is often very
knowledgeable about his or her own right
they enjoyed democracy however is a
democracy of inefficiency created by a
multitude of organizations that do not
produce a strong social and political
effect so far it created an ramified
network of organizations that largely
failed to influence in any significant
way the political climate in the country
both revolutions where the revolution
skeptically NGOs spectac
missed and this symptomatic that they
only in geo that emerged after the April
Revolution was a paramilitary
organization militia of sorts called
Patriots only help to observe maintain
some sense of order and this is the
point I want to stress as long as we
continue to perceive care gives NGOs as
a form of alternative politics or civic
participation they would continue to
look ineffective if not wasteful however
if we approach this structure created by
thousands of Kurds NGOs is an old
alternative form of organizing social
relations in distributing resources in a
situation of societal fragmentation this
form of activity would appear as highly
successful and to conclude and somewhat
polemical note 20 years of
post-socialist experiences have produced
a variety of analytical models and
interpretive frameworks predominantly
they have been structured around the
paradigm of transition and development
and could not quite capture the dynamic
of changes in / socialist world and the
return on the grade game framework this
morning is quite simple symptomatic they
still liking convincing frameworks that
could explain in new terms in your
situation in post-soviet world I don't
have a solution but I'm during my work
in Kyrgyzstan and dollars I begin to
realize more and more prominently that
maybe we should shift our analytical
focus a bit you start gradually coming
to terms with the fact that they
followed the Soviet empire did not just
create a a post-imperial situation
former USSR but also it produced a very
complicated post-colonial condition with
a very weak state a lack of resources
fragmented society in the vision of the
future with that has to be articulated
think
well I I think we can thank everyone
probably these four people know more
about Kyrgyzstan than any comparable for
people in the United States speaking on
behalf of the davis center we also tried
to have someone from Central Asia bucket
Mishima who is with us as a as a scholar
in peril in Cambridge but he had to be
somewhere else I'd like to invite the
panelists to to answer each other's
points I'll just make two comments i
ended up a little more optimistic than i
had expected because of sarah Gabe not
just pointing out the as you're looking
forward not simply pointing out the
proliferation of self-organizing groups
in society as a possible alternative to
the facility and the disintegration
fragmentation that characterizes it but
also that the state I work for a state
for 35 years it's kind of thankless if
you're an American but because we don't
Americans don't much like the state I
think the state is can be of a solution
as well as a problem and I was impressed
that the social group that with which
people identified most was still the
state which I think can provide a
framework into which a nation and a
citizenry can grow if you can make it
work the second i'll share with you a
memory when i was coordinator of
assistance to the former Soviet space in
the mid 90s kyrgyzstan was number two on
a per capita basis in the assistance
that we gave it was only after Armenia
and of course the Kyrgyz didn't have a
lobby like the Armenians did that could
get 99 signatures in senators signing up
for more aid to Armenia so it was sort
of remarkable but it had remarkable
effects if you've been in a
room there with a kife reading The
Federalist Papers to Warren Christopher
who had no idea why this was happening
you have been in a moment of high
diplomatic drama but with that let me
let me invite the panelists to pick up
on each other's points and I'd
especially like them perhaps to think
about what would be the way forward I
mean toward toward stabilization I'm n
development in this highly fragmented
family-oriented clan oriented we've
emphasized that situation I had a couple
of questions I'm okay ah I guess 11 is
for Sergei and and that is wonder if you
have any sense of what the currency of
nationalism is now in the post jun 2010
environment and that is are we are we
seeing the painful kind of the forging
of nationalism out of blood and steel
that we have seen in other places and
then this is a broader question maybe
it's for Kurt I don't know Curt and his
colleague and and and I and others have
been having this debate about the way
forward in Kyrgyzstan but I think it can
equally be answered by people here and
and for a long time I've been very
concerned about this does the strong
support for democratization efforts in
Kyrgyzstan precisely for the reasons of
the risking of violence on the way to
democracy and it kind of the jun 2010
events that we've seen and I've been
pushing a kind of let's think about what
happens when we go forward very quickly
but but last week I had to teach
Barrington more my graduate class and of
course the central point of barrington
more is you know you know get to
democracy without a lot of pain in blood
and maybe I guess the disturbing
conclusion is well maybe this is this is
what has to happen if if Kyrgyzstan is
is to go forward now I don't like the
implications of that argument but maybe
maybe more was on to something I don't
know I'd also like to invite people to
line up those who have some questions
because we like some questions from
audience to Scott I have to say it's not
if if you aren't advisor an advisor to
the kyrgyz government you're the next
best thing well thank you well tell
Rosie you said then I I guess I would
start by expressing maybe a little bit
of pushback in skepticism about airplane
analogies you know a political
scientists naturally focus their
analysis on the political leaves at the
top that's the core of what you're
saying I mean as a lawyer that's what I
do too i spend a lot of time talking to
elites and yet they're not the state and
they're not the nation and it's
something more than that and we have to
broaden out our focus quite a bit and I
think in fact I think one of the things
that to me has just been fascinating
about cured Assad as long as I've been
there is as Eugene husky likes to say
this is a nation of Natural Born
anarchists regardless of how they reply
and the polls in fact when you talk to
them with the consistent since the first
time I just did the Republic which was
in 1991 before the collapse of the
Soviet Union I heard disparagement of
the state like I heard nowhere else in
the former Soviet territory and after
kyrgyzstan became its independent it
gained independence of course they like
the idea of a sovereign and independent
kyrgyzstan they were proud of it on the
other hand there was this constant push
back of we don't need so much state we'd
be thankful that much less state thank
you there's no other place I've heard
that and heard that consistently and you
certainly hear it in the rhetoric of a
lot of the baluch leaders today and um
yeah maybe it's chaos but you know I
don't know maybe it's not necessarily
the kind of chaos I view is something
really horrible are catastrophic
normally I think chaos is something at a
catastrophic and certainly for a lawyer
it's something terrible but I also come
back and and say I think the
anthropological a perspective here is
really very important and so much of the
Lirin so much of what we read the ins
political scientists talking about these
very high level elites I think you have
to reach deeper into this country and I
have seen for a long time exactly what
Sergei said about
the NGO community the NGO community in
Kyrgyzstan is absolutely vibrant it's
all over the place it has a life that's
completely independent of the government
and it provides this sort of successful
net that exists what whatever happens to
the state that's independent of the
state that's a really remarkable thing
and I think if we look back in a lot of
the sociological literature I mean from
mux labor and earlier on I mean they
talked about the formation of highly
successful modern democratic states and
they pushed they pointed to the
existence of of healthy NGO networks as
really one of the most critical
indicators of a long-term successful
democracy that's a very very positive
sign here not to speak of the tuc feel
ya sherbert I only had one percent after
me so not much questions raised but one
thing that I came up with in during the
discussion with other scholars was the
way how Kyrgyz people tend to answer it
in the surveys on whether I'm keg is
where I'm piggies tourney with a member
of my tribe and they're being from a
very rural area where we would discuss I
can tell you that we really have very
acute sense of political correctness and
out tend not to really take seriously
the way how people answer in the formal
question especially coming if if the
interview is coming the street if
pouring it that's completely yeah but if
you leave there as most anthropologists
do and to spend two years and you get a
sense of what they really feel but on
the on Eric's question about whether we
need pain and blood probably to make
democracy real outside probably
Kyrgyzstan I hate to say that would need
pain and blood to create the state first
and then once you have the state
existing you can talk about the way how
state must be government as of now the
way this organized
the positive optimistic anarchy is
basically about lack of the state or
minimal state and maybe that's the way
how democracy still rests in the minds
of most greatest people but if we are to
establish Kyrgyzstan as a vibrant not
suicidal but as a vibrant state the key
problem in the minds of some circles at
least is that kyrgyzstan still have a
very fresh memory of pre russian history
of kyrgyz existence which was what
various tribes never a cake is state in
the rhetoric lots of movements from
Mountain to mountain and then you have
Russians and the Soviet Union drawing
the border and saying your cake is now n
cake is done and then in 99 you have
well independence imposed cake is done
as well as Central Asian countries both
overwhelmingly to keep solid Union as it
is but we failed so that's what we have
and I think that's partially explains
the way that the whole notion of
citizenship and the rule of law problems
come from there but maybe that's not too
bad as the optimistic Anarchy argument
caution thank you Sergei um nationalism
is extremely interesting phenomenon
there and I was watching on I left the
country I made them June so after the
programs but before sort of the
political changes and what was
interesting to me was that so what was
happening at Sur moment like several
organizations NGOs again got together
and decided to have a general kind of
campaign of mutual forgiveness right so
who's bags were telling you the care
gates of forgive us and the other way
around right so what it does basically
is serve its server but an interesting
embodiment again look up this formula
let's agree to disagree right and what
did what did basically produces it it
until and centralizes this ethnic
differences again and again right and
what bothers me a bit like after my
discussions with the
scholars NGO activists and cultural
figures is that there is a very strong
reluctance to discuss in civic journals
the issues of nationalism there is no
language there is a becomes extremely
emotional very very quickly and unless
its service its talk through on at some
level in some practices it's not going
to go away right so far it has been
suppressed for the last for 20 years or
so right it has been ignored but look it
won't go away unless where you find an
accessible language to talk about state
and Scott some interesting comment it's
interesting that you stopped right
before where local Kyrgyz would jump
into a discourse on nama deism right i
mean like sriracha topics women when i
was in bishkek there are two topics that
every discussion would evolve into one
is tribalism and sort of locality and
the importance of clans and the other
one but we we are the nomads right and
when I asked them well okay when did you
know may it last time right nobody did
it like it did your parents know me no
they didn't so like how calm it becomes
a part of your culture so like on what
kind of genetic level it gets translated
serving and then transmitted so there is
no answer in that again like that's what
bothers me as an anthropologist so couch
it is not kind of being printed in
Europe I are you know jeans right so
it's learned it's produced and liquid
what what I think what social scientists
should be doing there actually is to
have survived a comprehensive course on
nationalism and serve a nation
production that well yeah I learned
traditions that we tend to incorporate
and I condenser cannot separate
ourselves from them and the last one on
NGOs I totally agree with you like it's
a it's a very interesting sir framework
and so on so far with one problem it's
mostly foreign-funded and as soon as
serve this finding is gone sort of it's
not and there is no viable surf support
there is no sir working on
infrastructure anymore thank you first
question if you could identify yourself
i'm peter Sinnott i traveled to bishkek
on my own in mid-june business
interested in a referendum because i
have some Uzbek language ability I went
to osh on the twenty-fourth and the 25th
and the the question that is profound
and simple one which came out over and
over again is how do we go back how do
we how can we return to living in
Kyrgyzstan how can we have a future as
aspects in Kyrgyzstan now there was a
the actual pogrom had a very
personalized nature for every person
because they went to every room because
they killed all the animals and because
they cut the vines and burned them and
and the sniper the way the snipers acted
as well so going from this point and
realizing that on April fifteenth we had
already seen the Russian neighborhoods
barricaded in bishkek we had already
seen the Machine Turks under a bit of
siege as well we have to ask for
Kyrgyzstan in this new era of
nationalism and it is and we're in a
period now two weeks after an election
where we don't have certainty except for
nationalist parties being in a multitude
we have to ask and this is the question
that was given in the central mosque on
the late afternoon of friday in fish in
bishkek by the Uzbek Imams you know do
we come back is there a way we can come
back together or is there a division is
there as shani is there a point where we
have separated and we must separate so
um this is my question is after OSHA how
do we put relations back together well
just just to jump in there the curious
have asked the OSCE the oh dear for help
and how to put together a coalition
government so part of it may be mediated
through parties but of course it's
obviously a much much larger question
than that comment how do we how do you
put things back together I'll say
something I think you know we should
remember of course that we had these
this violence previously in June of 1990
in fact i was out there shortly after
that they spent a lot of time the
markets interviewing people and they
succeeded in putting things back
together after that
in fact I think there was a sort of
widely accepted narrative after the fact
that that this was not some
long-simmering ethnic dispute between
Uzbek sand Kyrgyz rather there was some
sort of outside instigation that went on
other people were always fuzzy about
what it was seems interesting to me but
I think you know that period immediately
after nineteen ninety on booze vexing
Kyrgyz lived together comfortably in
fact I think you know the Uzbek
community certainly flourished and I
think right now again it's interesting
when you interview people about what
happened there's an almost universal
acceptance of the fact that this was
first of all the word poem is absolutely
accepted this is what everyone says and
secondly it's it's almost universally
accepted that this was politically
instigated what there's a dispute about
is exactly who was involved in the
political instigation but most people
see this as something that was done for
broader political purposes by people
outside of these original community so I
think I think it should be possible to
reconcile but i think the country as a
whole has to work very hard at it
there's a lot for the government to do
there's a lot for OSCE to do and I think
the police assistance is going to be
critical there's a lot for the education
sector to do as well for universities
and schools because that's where the
sort of civic experiment has to be real
it I think in the school's very very
briefly yeah I think Scott's right that
there are lessons that can be learned
but I just want to not not to throw
water on the party but point out a
couple different things in 1990 you did
although the Soviets they didn't restore
the party the Soviet state did restore
order and you had really you had a had a
much more wrenching aftermath in this
case I think that's different the other
thing that's fundamentally different is
in every single neighborhood and every
single ethnicity that I went to in
southern Kyrgyzstan the first thing that
people did was pull out their cell
phones and just show absolutely horrific
images of what happens so the
documentation of this event is going to
live on much more than the documentation
of the previous one and the detail of
graphic images is just
it's astounding and then they just one
of the things that I would say for the
for the benefit of anybody with the
government who may be in the audience is
that I could you know who you are there
was an early optimism among certain
parts of the US government in June that
we had trained all of these wonderful
people working for NGOs and the user
were a reserve army that could
immediately go in and help to restore
this cooperation well when you speak to
this reserve army of NGOs they are as
traumatized by this and as / this as the
rest of society so we don't have this
reserve army and actually they're
actually in see any agreement on the
term pogroms rather what I saw was two
different sides yelling at one another
and blending one another with no
agreement whatsoever that there should
be culpability assigned to one side of
the other so we're just a quick one um
to play a political science card and to
talk a little bit about the importance
of structures and institutions and one
of the solutions could be for instance
to start discussion about this second
state language like I was amazed during
the discussion of the draft of the
constitution that was back language as a
possibility for the second state
language was completely dismissed and by
now we have one look about 25 percent of
those bags living in the country why
there is not even a discussion Russian
is the official language post documents
are done in Russian courtesies the state
language was back is not present and
that creates a lot of mistrust saying
the same goes for the TV channel signals
back language in bishkek for instance
and many other places do we have
programs in those back language that
would be available for the whole country
what's really so there was a lot of
cultural politics that has not been done
next question thank you Tom thanks for a
great panel my name is Frederick shoberg
I'm the Harriman Institute visiting
scholar an expert on politics of in
Kyrgyzstan actually on clown so called
clan politics very interesting panel
it's kind of a symptomatic of
central asian studies that we don't have
any economists here I just want to
myself being a political scientist it's
going to wear to to say that but I just
want to highlight that next week undp is
going to publish the 2010 human
development report and Kyrgyzstan is one
of the only few countries in the world
that actually has a lower human
development in 2010 converted 1990 so
going back to the plane analogy from
eric i think that focusing on the elite
level you know be interesting that's
what i've been doing in a lot of my
doctoral work as well i think we need to
take the plane level the plane analogy
we need to analyze both what's going on
on the ground and what's going on above
the plane and there i'm referring to
russia as being sort of the ground
control and in this sort of flying back
and forth so i think we need to both
look at the ground level demand for
change and apparently whatever we've
been doing in Kyrgyzstan hasn't worked
for the people so there's clearly going
to be that might be the explanation for
the shorter and shorter cycles of
stability in Kyrgyzstan and then of
course the role of Russia being being
central in in tours over in terms of
setting up the game for for locals local
elites and incentivizing them and
clearly in April Russia withdrew their
support from the Bakke of government and
that's exactly what triggered them the
the downfall but I also have two
comments 1 comment on one question Scott
thank you so much for clarifying this
whole thing I think Kyrgyzstan is the
biggest foreign policy blunder of
Obama's first term in office and for
those who you are Americans I would
really take this to heart amazing good
to hear it from you Scott it's not about
a rogue ambassador in a faraway country
this is a policy that completely failed
this is the price of the the Afghan war
escalation etc this is a big thing that
people in this country doesn't seem to
these timings really grouchy and then to
Shah Rukh like a good to have you in the
States what do you think about the
survival
the parliamentary systems the system
clearly a unique system in a central
asian context but there might actually
be a majority there is a majority to
over throw it in the new Parliament it
might not be a constitutional majority
but if Putin gets in they have 82 of 120
seats which means two-thirds right so
the survival of the parliamentary system
Constitution that was adopted last
summer that would be glad to hear some
of your comments on that thank you I'm
sorry to say I'm going to take one last
question and then ask the panel to to
address both of those Thank you Thank
You panelists my name is Brian futuna ch
I work at the UN covering central asia i
wanted to at least pose the question
that this positive anarchy may have been
institutionalized already I know
characterizing the April events is
difficult and controversial but a coup
to me speaks of an organized plan a
People's Movement to me requires some
ideology or platform which I've left to
hear yet to hear and if democracy is
going to cost something somewhere it
seemed that people have paid and
southern is better kyrgyzstan already
and in blood and why was there no
further violence i think it's the
paradoxical responsive who's becca stone
and in that case that seems like a very
fragile guarantee for stability and I
would wonder then if we there's not a
degree of projection that this is a
positive anarchy given the regimes in
the neighbouring countries it might seem
better than it is thank you good
Oh Frederick yeah providentially our
organizers have have given us a next
panel at which Russia will appear what
went on on Uzbekistan that debt fit it
has me very concerned is is if indeed I
mean I take your point Sergei that the
discussion on nationalism is awkward to
say the least but if that discussion has
begun and it's a discussion that is
predominately being led by cured East
nationalist whatever we define that as
yet Curie's dawn as a state that doesn't
have a military so to speak doesn't have
an army and is doing what it may be
indirectly sponsoring what we saw in the
south what's to stop the state that's
next door that does have a national
identity that does have an army that
does have a military from sending forces
across the border or if the leader might
want to not do that with it what
guarantee do we have that that leader
can stop other people within his country
in Uzbekistan from going across the
border and stopping the violence that
we've seen so I mean this is it this is
the you know the thing that worries me
about this whole chaos of the state the
weakness of the state and this already
paying in blood I really fear that there
could be much more blood to come as a
result I think however with all the
neighbors worried and frightened and
interested in stability their
self-interest does not go toward
intervention I think that's true of
Uzbekistan I think the Russians
certainly demonstrated it in response to
the request for csto peacekeepers were
they very early they decided and told us
that they had decided that that was not
what their policy was going to be I'm
going to stop it there so that we can
freshen ourselves up for the next
exciting panel and let us give a big
hand to the panelists for this
you